as I understand it the very first thing
that you shot for Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one scene one was
the motorcycle jump yes why uh get it
out of the way
um if anything goes wrong it'll
it'll be a very short production
uh and were you worried uh oh yeah we're
always worried we're always uh uh we're
always cautious but
um you you have to focus on everything
that can go right not everything that
could go wrong
so what kind of planning went into it
um months of planning we actually we
built a shorter version of the ramp at a
quarry in the United Kingdom
filled it with cardboard boxes and we
had a we had a cable system so Tom could
do the entire jump but there was a cable
that would catch him rather than have
him fall into the Quarry
and that was to help us line up all the
cameras and figure out what technology
we were going to use and how we were
actually going to get the shot
all of that went out the window as soon
as we got to Norway everything
everything changed but you got to get
the cameras right because there's no
value in having Tom Cruise speed down a
Mountainside and off of a cliff if you
don't have the shot correct the the
challenge normally when you're shooting
an action movie is you're always trying
to hide the fact that it's a stunt man
and not the actor in Mission Impossible
it's the opposite you're you're trying
to show that it is Tom and not a stunt
man so you always have to find a way to
put a camera somewhere where it'll both
see him in close-up but not be in his
way when he's doing the stunt and that
actually gets to the point that the
stunts are so incredible that people
might not believe it's really him there
are still people who do not believe that
it's him
you've met these people I meet people
occasionally you I I see things online
where people just they they don't
believe it they don't want to believe it
one of these days I'm going to bring one
of those people to set and just have
them watch them I've I've read that at
the end of each Mission Impossible film
because you've done how many now four
I'm in between my third and fourth yeah
Tom has a tradition of turning to you in
the Final Cut final screening and saying
what we can do better
yes
meaning what uh meaning and it's not
just Mission Impossible it's every movie
we do we can uh We're Never Satisfied we
we look at what we've done we we see
where the holes are
um any criticism that
we might hear about the movie is
something we've already said and looked
at and and said how can we do better
next time and this is a working
relationship that goes back now all the
way to what 2006 2006 yeah what is that
relationship like
um it I like to describe it as one long
conversation about movies that's
occasionally interrupted by production
by actual movies by actual movies yes uh
we just love movies love entertaining an
audience is really what it's about that
was our very first meeting was talking
about the kind of movies we wanted to
make why we make movies and Tom was
somebody who was very straightforward
about I make Mass entertainment and in
the relationship when it comes to the
story and the stunts yeah what comes
first and who pushes whom
um there's no chicken and egg and we're
pushing each other I think we're pushing
each other we're challenging one another
when you work with Tom you find yourself
doing things you didn't think you were
capable of doing most days you don't
know how the day is going to end you go
in with a plan but you're not you know
obsess about that plan uh and no and we
both know that nobody knows everything
the the more we work together the more
we'll tell each other check your
certainty the more you feel like you
know what the answer is the more likely
you are to be surprised in the editing
room when you didn't have it with Tom
Cruise as your actor yeah it feels like
he could do any stunts yeah how do you
determine whether a stunt is worth it
doable is one thing yes worth it is
another uh you ask a very good question
the short answer is that the motto that
came out of this movie was this is a
terrible idea when do we start
if something seems ill-advised there's
probably there's probably something to
it and then uh and and you asked a very
good question which is is it worth it
um any feeling in the movie whether it's
a stunt whether it's a a joke uh some
some psych gag we've learned to evaluate
the time and effort and resources that
go into it and I'll come to Tom and say
this is how much this feeling costs it
because that's really what it's all
about to us is how it feels how it
affects you emotionally the audience is
feeling yes and at the end of every
movie Tom says to you we can do better
yes what more could you possibly do you
will see